passive income is money you earn that
doesn't require you to do a lot of
active work to continue making it
here are some passive income ideas to
help you make money in 2022
one build and monetize a Blog
one of the most popular passive income
stream originates from blogging
blogging has helped countless
entrepreneurs earn passively through
affiliate links courses sponsored posts
products book deals Etc so if you're
looking for an easy passive income idea
blogging might be the perfect option for
you
2. create and sell online courses
if you're an expert in some subject or
field selling online courses may be a
great passive income idea for you
whether you sell them through your own
website or online learning platforms
like udemy you'll find plenty of
individuals who are willing to pay to
access your content
three invest in stocks
when analyzing the income sources of the
world's richest people it's pretty safe
to say that stocks have played a big
role in their deep endless bank accounts
stock Investments can help you earn
passive income so consider this passive
income idea if you're up to date on
various markets and Industry movements
four create and sell digital products
digital products are media assets dot
they are downloadable files such as
audio books PDFs templates or plugins
digital products have high profit
margins because no inventory or storage
costs are incurred
you only have to make the asset once and
you can sell it repeatedly
there's no limit on the number of copies
you can sell
5. start a YouTube channel
YouTube is the passive income stream
that just keeps on giving
from sponsored videos to ad Revenue
you'll find that you can make recurring
income from your YouTube channel
the secret to creating a successful
YouTube channel is creating content on a
consistent schedule for a long time
make sure every video you upload is well
made and something people want
if you stick with it for the long haul
you'll eventually start reaping the
passive income Rewards
thank you for watching